the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it but with the
adana you can use it in perfect
alignment with your life the adan app is
already used by 40 million believers
around the world why because it caters
to your islamic lifestyle on top of this
a lot of times you get their eyes
podcast in the dunya the three muslims
we're here with the home base again at
the home base welcome everyone salaam
alaikum how are you guys doing
you know what they say bro those who
have the most strength speak the least
um
i've never heard that idea in my life
now you know all right alhamdulillah
this power and silence isn't that right
on her well of course he's not gonna say
anything because he's he's powerful
but today insha allah will open up a
little bit more as the podcast goes on
yes so as we discussed very important
stuff today we were talking about this a
little bit before we came to the you
know studio
and it's a topic about money
money
does money make a man
no but a man should make money
that's what it is bro that's what it is
bars
okay okay
go into that bro
all right
money don't make a man but a man should
be making money it's profound what i
mean by this exactly what i just said
um
money cannot make a man can't buy a man
can't do anything really
but men should have money man of the
provisioners none of the protectors
that's why they call him the man right
uh you know you see someone who's rich
who's famous or whatever you know
they're like oh that's the man oh you
the man blah blah whatever
right
money doesn't make a man though
uh
many things make a man actually i would
say
right money doesn't make a man
what makes a man
would be a man who makes money
but it's not the money in and of itself
it's the fact that he can make it it's
the fact that he can support his
families the fact that he is resourceful
enough to be able to go out of his way
produce different means avenues to
be a supporter and provider and so on
and so forth
yes
someone jump on that but the salafis are
wondering where is the source from quran
and sunnah this is haram come on
i understand you're saying this you know
i'm gonna go make millions but the
millions don't make me cool you're
giving bars but what is the quran so now
when it comes to this i believe there
was a hadith that i that i was reading
i'm not 100 sure on this again you know
so forgive me the salafis mashallah but
i'm not 100 sure if this is hadith from
the quran but i've heard multiple you
know refer to this and it's the idea
that verily being close to poverty makes
you close to being a disbeliever
not in the sense that you can't have
taqwa or iman being you know low income
or being in poverty but it's the sense
that shaytan doesn't come to you
advocating haram options to make money
when you already have enough money
it's only when you have no money that
you think about stealing even if you
don't steal but at least the thought is
more likely to come across your mind you
know what i mean
or at least i should do this i should do
that just to get out of poverty i should
steal i should go rob someone or even
though you're not gonna do it but it's
not gonna come to you if you're making
steady halal income let's say 100k a
month you get me so
i do believe that and i think that to
some extent allah has made it our
obligation as men like brother rami said
to provide and protect our women folk
right and in today's material
world unfortunately
runs on money
so you don't need to have you know you
don't need to be a billionaire or
anything like that but you do need to
bring in basic
income
basic provisioning put a roof over your
family's head your loved one take care
of your parents inshaallah allah sooner
the better uh you know put food on table
medical expenses that type of thing you
know
so this begs the question bro
why are so many muslim men today
not financially savvy
[Music]
i think because they're comfortable
i think they're because they're
comfortable and they are focusing
primarily
on the akhira which there's nothing
wrong with that
you know we should definitely be
learning more
about the dean about islam and all this
but when you focus primarily on the
akhira then
you figure the dunya and there should
always be a balance
you know and and if if you get married
as a man
if you have a wife i'm always looking
the camera like looking the people in
their souls you know should be looking
at y'all i'm talking to y'all right so
if if you're a man you get married
then
part
or possibly
the thing that might bring you into
jannah is
your wife 100
or your kids
and vice versa yeah so okay as a man
like romney said
uh money doesn't make a man but a man
should make money
right so
if your job as a man is to be the
provider
how are you gonna do that with no money
yeah if
the woman that you have your wife
is an opportunity for you to go to
jannah if you actually take care of her
and fulfill her rights how you gonna do
that if you're not making any money no
all right like how you gonna feed her if
you're not making any money how are you
gonna feed yourself are you gonna feed
your kids
are you gonna take care of your family
yeah you know like how can you do
anything substantial in this world um if
you don't have money and
maybe maybe i'm ignorant and saying that
yeah yeah 100 uh not 100 percent you're
ignorant but 100 to your point
100 to your point i do want to jump in
here and and and kind of clear something
up i can't speak on you guys behalf
right i'm pretty sure beyond the same
page inshallah i'm not talking about
people who
are not super wealthy i'm not super
wealthy
i'm not talking about people who are
poor
i'm talking about people who are
not go getters who are not hard workers
people who maybe they grew up very
comfortable like you mentioned in life
and they don't focus on expanding their
avenues to make more money
that's what i'm mainly focusing i see
that and that's what i'm trying to get
at too yeah again like i said maybe i'm
ignoring you maybe i'm just not
explaining it correctly
but um there are some men out here
muslim men who
they
they choose not to go hard and make that
money yeah
and therefore they say ah well you know
what it's okay for me and my wife to go
50 50.
yeah you see now they like they've given
up the provider yeah now they're like
they're basically like oh the woman's a
provider as well stuff
you know or they get to the point where
they're not providing anything yeah and
then they're over here depending on
their woman and the woman's paying for
everything
we're not against women working with
context
and a woman having own money of course
because that is on islamic to say
otherwise
but what we are saying is most women
love to feel secure and security is
extremely important to women
it's not the money in and of itself that
a woman wants you to have but it's the
symbol of security
trust reliance
that women are lacking today bro
this whole revolution on on on women
wanting to be independent because they
couldn't trust the man
for whatever means whether he couldn't
provide he couldn't protect so i need to
go do this xyz myself i need to go
spread my wings outside the house just
so i can feel more secure i need to take
everything into my own hands when allah
has made it a man's responsibility to do
so
yeah yeah so how do we get started with
this
how is a man today who's let's say 14 15
because of course we're going to talk to
the kids that are you know
older teenagers and all that too but i
do want to talk i do want to start to
people today at least chronologically
because
i want to be the change that i didn't
have growing up in terms of at least
podcasts and youtube obviously because
back then we were watching you know
stupid stuff on like ytv and all that
and spongebob and all that but see back
then you know you have 13 14 euros today
subhanallah there are young kids
watching us right yeah what should they
do what do you guys think as kids that
are still living on money
in terms of just habits that you start
building
i would say first and foremost uh
actually you know
i would say everything
and also business endeavors it doesn't
start with
business and and practicing business and
learning and so on and so forth it
starts with islam one of every single
thing sorry with islam you even
understand business from an islamic
perspective
and and fix those affairs and you're
first with allah first and foremost
because only then can you really say
that you have the right intention you're
going about it the right way and insha
allah allah will set you up for success
so learn what business is from the same
perspective learn the context of
business allah
is very beautiful he says in surah
he says when the then is called for
friday friday prayer go and basically
pray right i'm paraphrasing a bit and
the translation as well go and pray but
once the prayer is concluded go out and
seek the bounty of allah right actually
let me let me correct myself allah
specifically says leave trade and go and
pray right he says stop business stop
trading
yeah and then go pray and then when it's
once it's done come back and
seek the bounty of allah or go out and
take the bounty of allah in the world so
we should have the same context that
we're doing business until it's time to
pray
fulfill obligations right do what we
need to do for the sake of allah and it
might have to do with their families as
well by obligations towards our families
ourselves our loved ones allah so on and
so forth and then go out and see the
bounty of allah and i'm going to give
the floor to you guys to talk more so
about what comes after that see bro
what you said reminds me of when i went
to saudi arabia from umrah yeah and then
i went to uae as well
things are different there bro when it's
when it's time see wallahi it pains me
to get dms from brothers and sisters
today saying i have a job and it's it's
a good income job that i'm going to take
on inshaallah and it's going to require
me to miss uh asir
or prayer well i'm going to hit all of
them except maghrib what should i do
and it reminds me of when i went to
saudi and subhanallah bro when it's time
for salah
all the stores have a barricade a gate
restaurants everything everything just
goes on pause as soon as the adhd is
called all the stores
close just like you said trade stops
trade stops
and
store keepers start walking to the
masjid people outside that are cleaners
start walking so much dude
everyone that works at a fast food place
starts going to the masjid
and they pray and things cannot open and
resume back to business until 30 minutes
after the event was called meaning that
not only do you go pray it's enough time
for people that are not near masjid to
go to masjid
and you come back
and you resume like nothing happened
because nothing revolves around work bro
everything revolves around sallah
and taqwa keeping allah in mind that's
one thing i wanted to just touch on your
point but
a practical point that i'll give and
inshallah it's a very you know profound
and applicable one that i started doing
in my life was the rule of percent have
i told you guys about this
i heard the 80 20 but i haven't heard
the 10 see
this is going to be something that could
either
make or break someone's saving account
and we're going to talk into you know
cryptocurrency and investments obviously
in the future inshallah but just for the
sake of saving money i think as 14 year
olds 13 year olds watching this it's not
too early to understand and learn the
skills of saving money and one of the
most important thing is the rule of ten
percent so basically
from this moment on anyone watching this
right i don't care if you're 10 i don't
care if you're 20 i don't know if you're
30 i don't if you're 80 years old
every dollar that enters your bank
you're gonna save ten percent of it into
a separate account non-negotiable you're
not touching that account you're not
taking money out of that account you're
not going to be low on your funds take
money from that account and then when
you get paid put it back into the
account none of that that account is
strictly going to be the 10 account and
you're putting in 10 of everything you
get paid a thousand dollars on friday
you're putting in a hundred dollars you
get 500 for for eid money you put in 50.
no matter what it is even if it's chump
change you're just putting in 10 of it
i don't care how young you are you're
gonna start this now
over time you're gonna notice this is
gonna be a lot of money and for anyone
watching this that's 30 years old 40
years old if i ask you a question if you
save 10 of everything you made in your
life thus far how much do you guys think
you would have in that account
probably a lot
probably a lot but we didn't
i started doing this two years ago i'm
not gonna air anything out but let's
just say it's an amount that i probably
wouldn't have saved otherwise
and this doesn't mean you spend 90 i'm
just saying this is a separate account
for just 10 percent
there's other things we can talk about
for your portfolio how you should break
it down put it into finance put into
investments put it into real estate
other stuff but i believe minimum 10
should just go into the savings account
it's a very good way to start you can
get a little mini i don't want i don't i
don't know if piggy banks are halal bro
pick it like the kawaras are going to
take everything out of context bro he
they said piggy bank bro pigs are haram
listen
we have piggy banks in canada it's
basically a little thing where you put
your looney or your toony or your
quarters anything you get but have
something if you don't have a bank
account if you have a bank account um
ask your parents to open one if you
don't you don't say hey mom hey dad i
want to open an account i want to learn
more about you know
saving money and i want to get more
financially savvy you know
but 10 of your income goes a long way
so so how do they start making any kind
of income to be able to save see the 14
year olds 13 roles that i'm talking
about are the ones that get the income
from said chump change like here's some
eid money here's some gift money you
know your grandmother comes here
abuela's come you know parents are not
there abuela slips you like a fifty
dollar note you put five of that into
that that's what i'm talking about
obviously you know we're gonna talk
about as the ages go on into later teens
and early adulthood early adolescents
when you start you know making money at
a job then it's way more easy you have
cash flow coming in you can put 10 aside
but for everyone no matter how much you
have
you can't tell me that you're spending
more than 90 of your income if otherwise
then
you shouldn't even be on youtube
watching us to be honest to be frank you
should be doing something else with your
time but 10 of your money i think is
bare minimum
and this is something that you might
think it's not much now because you only
probably make like 50 a year because
you're so young
gift money or eid money or whatever but
this is a habit that you must found the
foundate right now you must find the
habit right now build this foundation so
in a couple years when you're making
money you're making let's say 10k a year
then you're making inshallah 5k a month
and 5k uh every week insha'allah if you
can get to that point maybe even more
insha'allah
it's going to be easy you're not going
to feel some type of way putting 10 in
because you've done it for so long yeah
so don't look at it as okay i'm 14 how
do i make a million now
because you see people making you know
million dollars on nfts at age 16.
walking into high school with
lamborghinis we're not here to you know
promise you and overshoot that promise
what we are saying is you can build
foundational habits today
which don't require much both 10 is
nothing right if i if i give you a
thousand dollars and i'm i'm saying you
have to give me a hundred dollars you
won't mind right
it's a good habit to build and i think
it'll go a long way if you put it to
practice inshallah yeah 100
uh before angel jumps in if he wants to
inshallah uh you remind me of a video i
watched based on a book right that i did
not read to be fair um about atomic
habits have you guys heard about it
atomic habits there's even building
habits and i want to talk about it
because you mentioned it even building
habits is almost like a skill in and of
itself or an entire practice um
because obviously there's good and bad
habits right and if you look at one of
your bad habits like nail biting right
that's a bad habit i have if you look at
when these things look good sky staring
at my nails don't look at my nails man
you bite your nails yeah i do i bite my
nails your bad habits dirty boy bro
this is haram
actually i can't pull that i don't know
if it's wrong to be honest but do you
swallow it after no no that's why
okay that's too much you draw the line
somewhere yeah
if you look at like me personally if i
look at where these things when i buy my
nails usually either when i'm bored or
when i'm nervous when i'm anxious so if
i were to never be bored anxious or
nervous i would never bite my nails
right and
it's about also setting the right
environment for yourself right that's
very important if you had a father
that encouraged or enforced you to
save 10 or something that would also
help tremendously if you don't you don't
have a role model like that or someone
like that you either have to become the
romantic yourself or surround yourself
with things that remind you of that
when i wanted to set certain if people
know me who you know if people have
known me for a long time they'll know i
had long long hair maybe you know a few
months a year ago right
that was actually a goal that i had i
actually had a goal to grow up my hair i
took all my goals you know start
learning
i3 start learning islam
start my platform grow my hair out work
out all these different things i wrote
them on a list and took a screenshot and
made that my screensaver so every time i
even open my phone which i do a lot
i would see that list and i did
basically everything right the gyms
closed down eventually which really you
know hurt that goal um and we're not
talking about working out from home this
guy gave me a nice workout plan
it was really good it was helpful but
that's another story so habits in and of
itself in building it just want to slip
that in there
because you mentioned it is so important
and there's actually a proper way to
build good habits
yeah what's the proper way
okay well you got us on the edge of our
seats bro
firstly watch the video it describes it
in depth the proper way to set or build
good habits or
there's two things right there's
breaking down bad habits and then
there's building good habits
to break down a bad habit to build a
good habit is basically the same but
almost it's the same in the same order i
would say first you have to look at what
the habit is what triggers these things
what kind of reward you get after the
habit and there's a few other things i'm
forgetting but i'll stick to what i
remember
like i mentioned the nail-biting thing
for some reason i don't know why i get
some kind of relief from biting my nails
because it calms me when i'm freaking
nervous or whatever right or anxious
if i were to pick up a better habit
that's more beneficial
that is triggered or that i consciously
do or
it's not unconscious yet but now it's
consciously that i do it when i'm
nervous that has a good reward i would
be able to replace my nail biting with
that because it's something that's
triggered when i'm anxious just like no
biting and it's something that's
rewarding as well so if you
were to
get some kind of
reward from let's say working out after
every single workout session you would
be more inclined to work out right
and this is actually something that's
very basic so if you look at the
environment that you have what triggers
you to want to do these habits whether
they're good or bad and then you look at
the reward and the outcome of it making
you more inclined to do it afterwards
that is something that is really going
to benefit you like let's say you do
this for a month or two months or three
months you put 10 away you might have a
few bucks you might have a few dollars
honestly but after a year two years
you're really you're probably going to
have the habit by then but you're going
to look at that account and be like i
have like a lot of money now and maybe
200 300 is a lot for a 13 14 year old
right thousand dollars 10 000 like being
rich for a 13 year old 14 year old but
when you see something like that it's
only going to encourage you more the
hardest stage is in the beginning
building those habits
money is one of these things um unlike
fitness and other you know pursuits in
life
that it's actually extremely difficult
in the beginning
um stuff like fitness let's say losing
weight or gaining muscle is actually
really easy in the beginning bro you
make most of your progress in the noob
games phase or early on
you've been working out five years it's
probably you know 10 results every year
after that very difficult but with money
it's the opposite the more money you
have the easier it is to make money so
with money the hardest thing is to begin
so what ram is saying is true because
you need to have these skills and and
the psychology and habit building that
too and the money will come i know you
guys are waiting like okay what stock
should i put my money and what
cryptocurrency is going to take off
which nft project is going to the moon
what you guys are saying is like the
unsexy answer to like all of this you
know these questions that i have but the
reality is wallahi
you're never going to make money
until making money is not your priority
it's something greater than that it's
who you're becoming in the process like
you know elliot says on his channel
yeah i know you gotta say something
i don't know romney sounded like he was
about to say something
honestly i really do so just uh to touch
on that point there
just touching that point there
um
having a goal is really important
especially tying into what i said
initially about having the right nia
because if you have the goal of making
money to be rich you know can you really
turn to allah and be like i had the
right intention i want to be rich
but if you have the intention of being
wealthy enough resourceful enough to
provide for your family and to help
those in need
masha'allah that's a beautiful cause
it's a beautiful intention to have and
that's something you should capitalize
on the next thing i want to say is
another very unsexy answer i guess you
could say uh which is
uh as far as i know personally i'm not
we're not going to tell you what stock
to invest in which cryptocurrency to
invest in you're going to do that
yourself you're going to find something
that works for you you're going to find
something that you're good at that you
can capitalize on or multiple things and
you're going to invest in those things
maybe it'll be a podcast maybe a youtube
channel maybe it'll be a business maybe
some services products goods whatever it
might be
you're going to find that yourself and
anyone who's going to come and tell you
oh do this invest in this and do this
current cryptocurrency
maybe they're telling the truth
maybe not maybe they're trying to sell
you a course so they can capitalize on
their avenue right
many courses out there we're not selling
courses today we're just speaking honest
hard truthful facts
i think the one thing that i want to add
to this
is uh something that
my roommate a long time ago told me
and uh
he's he's a multi multi-millionaire
pretty nice masha allah
he has said that uh
if you really want to get to the point
where you're making a lot of money i'm
still trying to internalize this by the
way so
i am by no way shape or form a
millionaire nor more time no we're we're
broke boys
[Music]
yes sir
so what he has said
is you you treated like a game
right like you guys played games
obviously i think every guy has played
video games
and in video games like let's say you're
playing uh gta probably not the best
example because it's not that halal of a
game hmm
what
so
playing gta or you're playing i don't
know some kind of game right
and in this game you can make money in
this game now let me ask you something
when you're playing this game
is your focus ever to make the money in
the game no
no
but you need it to progress exactly are
you gonna buy armor exactly but it's
like fire said like
the priority is not to make the money
was it you or was it was wrong okay it
was you
well you said
the priority is not to make the money
right you're playing this video game
your priority is not to make the money
but you need the money to get more armor
to get more weapons to progress in the
game right now as you play the game
as you start becoming in this game
whatever it is that you're doing this
game you start making more money you
start having more currency maybe you're
fighting more bosses you're getting more
loot whatever the case might be
right but the fact is you're making
the money
you're not trying to make the money it
doesn't feel like you're doing anything
really that substantial to make the
money and at the end of the day it's a
game you're enjoying your means bro
right and that's what my friend he said
it that it should be like that life
should be like this game where it's like
you're not taking it that seriously nor
are you focusing on the money but you're
actually doing other things to really
experience
this game you know um
you guys get what i'm saying right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and people in the comments are like what
what hadith was your roommate quoting by
the way
he's not most of my opinions yeah got
him though this is
[Music]
anything's possible bro
um
we are going to obviously talk about the
benefits of giving sataka charity
uh you know paying zakat obligation
right if we can
um how to avoid debt bro credit card
debt student loan debt all of these
things that are silent killers before we
talk about making money how do we stop
losing money right so we're gonna get
into all that but just as we talked
about thus far these are the basic
fundamentals that we want to have
one last thing um unless ramya has
anything else i did want to ask brother
angel a question it was a talk that we
had about a few months ago
about you know
your personal relationship with money
and how it changed a bit
and how it seems as something now you're
almost like out of your own way
you know do you wanna you know do you
feel comfortable sharing that bro
um
just the main takeaways
i think the biggest thing was that
i saw money as like
this thing where
um i don't know it was very crucial
it was like a big part and um it was not
something to be played around with
and it's like if someone was playing
with my money
it was a big issue
or like it was such a big issue that if
if um
i don't like i felt some type of way
that maybe charging people x amount of
money because i would think to myself no
no that's too much money like how can i
charge someone this much like they
probably have their own things that they
got to take care of
but it's like you start realizing like
okay money is a means to an end or
beginning it's a tool that's all it is
that's all it is and you shouldn't
remove any attachment that you have to
when you remove the attachments that's
when you start kind of changing your
perspective on money
and
that's where you can start actually
making a difference in
how you make the money that's the one
thing i was waiting for you to say bro
lose your attachment
this life is a testable life bro the
detachment to money is one of the best
feelings in the world bro
you're not slipping into disbelief
just to make money
you're not simping just for money
you're not out here working and slaving
your life away just for money you're not
sacrificing family time and having time
with your loved ones
because you're out here working overseas
just for money
not no dirt by the way to all the
fathers doing that may allah bless you
and preserve you for all the hard work
that you do
but
i grew up in a family that was a little
different from that you know i grew up
in a family that my parents they knew
that you know making money is important
but they also understood the value of
family time they knew making money is
important because well i brought we came
to canada as immigrants and and
mashallah my parents brought they
struggled i'm sure just like y'all's
parents did it right and it wasn't easy
bro we weren't born into a rich family
or anything so they really struggled
just to you know get us here and give us
a decent life bro
but simultaneously you know weekends
came we did little mini road trips
every few weeks we went on little
holidays whatever we could just to keep
that kinship that that tie with our
family that bonds strong you know so
imagine how much money in subhanallah we
were literally talking about this before
most of people wouldn't work
and and put so much time into a job
right if they actually had money so they
could do more of what they love and more
things for the sake of allah
so money isn't necessarily something
that makes you shallow or materialistic
or something that's evil
it could actually be your ticket to
getting more good deeds and staying away
from sins so i think the way we look at
money should change and it should no
longer be this thing that we're like you
know too shy to talk about and and we're
afraid of making money it's almost like
you're afraid of success
you can make six figures a year
inshallah you can even make six figures
a month maybe even more than that
it's not too far away you just have to
do the right thing for long enough
inshallah
bro and i just want to add
um
before i became the muslim
i was engaged
and uh
the fiance here um
i don't know we just had a little
connection yeah connection right there
but um
when i was when i was engaged
uh my fiancee's father at the time
he
he had brought this thing up to me where
he was like
um the money that you have is never
really yours
he's like
money is like it has to be in constant
flow
and if you think about it like
you
you didn't make this money right you
took it
and i think um there was another video i
don't know if it was imam gazi or if it
was tell you who had said this
but um you're never making the money
yourself you don't have an actual
money-making machine
you're taking it because of something
that you did you provided a service you
took it it's just it was just
it was it was a flow right you provided
a service you got the exchange now that
you have the money let's say you want
that ice cap
you got to give the money yeah right
they're not going to give you the ice
cap for free yeah it's like when we were
in walmart we were about to get that
water for free
but no you said no no i'm gonna pay for
this hold up boy no relax relax may
allah bless you uh but what i'm trying
to say is that there's there's a
constant flow right
then that's what the father was trying
to tell me he's like there's
the money's flowing so if you want this
then you got to pay for that and then if
if you want to sell something or you
want to do a service and you get the
money back but you can't hold on to
money if you if you hold on to money you
block the flow of money so if you
if you are stingy then it's like you
stop receiving
right so it's like when you realize this
you realize okay well if there's a
constant flow of if i keep giving if i
give more southika if i'm more free with
my money well then i'm going to receive
more in return
and um
[Music]
i think that's just another big point
that needs to be
brought in because people we we get very
stingy with money 100 bro this will tie
into inshallah what we should do with
our money
and uh
quick time check bro what are we looking
at
i don't know we got 20 minutes 20
minutes okay a little more 20 minutes
all that
okay cool with that being said if if you
know y'all don't have anything else
we can definitely discuss how we can
make money the basic fundamentals but i
think they should take another episode
too maybe but inshallah we'll try to go
over the basic fundamentals today um do
you all have anything before we go in i
want to give a disclaimer just about
myself this is not financial advice
and uh i'm more of a disclaimer about
myself as opposed to these two brothers
here masha'allah
i have not done any i've never had any
real big bigger business
endeavors to be completely honest so
everything i'm saying is completely
theoretical from my perspective from
their perspective masha'allah it's a lot
more practical because they've done it
for me it's a lot more theoretical at
least at this point bro i'm still
learning
i'm still learning bro um
you might know more than me bro
subhanallah who knows all we're doing is
sharing what we've come across so far
yes 100 that's it
okay
first most important thing this is the
fundamental thing that you all must
understand when it comes to working and
making money
is you have
active income and passive income
these are the two big things that we're
going to talk about so what are the
different what's the difference
active income is
you know there's multiple categories you
can work at a job right so you are an
employee
you can work for someone
um you can either you know hire people
and own a business like like i don't
know like an employer right but you're
still it's the active income because
even employers do you know they trade
time for money
stuff like that um
you could be a you know some trade or
anything like that right this is
basically even if you work for yourself
this is still active income there's
there's a link between time and money
work you do versus how much money you
make that hits your bank
passive income is different you know
these are things like business owners
per se you know these are people that
they've done the work they've opened the
businesses now they don't do anything
they have people to manage everything
you know they kind of i'll give you an
example do you have an ice cap on you or
no yeah mashallah let's pull this up bro
[Music]
i'll give you a wonderful example
we don't want to we don't want to spill
this on the on the road caster pro 2
martial there's a lot dropped on this uh
it's very expensive equipment but right
here over over here you know editor you
can zoom in on this bismillah we got
biebs crew or beeps brew all right
[Music]
what is this justin bieber the musician
the artist
rnb or whatever he does i don't know
what he does now but i don't even think
to be honest he's ever had an ice cap i
don't know i don't know if he even knows
what coloring went into this font or the
logo or anything like that you can put
this back by the way
what i do know is
he made a deal with them to give tim
horton's coffee company in canada the
rights to use his name to promote this
you know biebs ice cap or whatever
literally tastes the same to me i don't
know about you right i don't know what
biebs brew is
but here's the thing
does he trade time for this
does he come into tim hortons every day
no
it's just an endorsement that makes him
the passive income
through using his title and or or i
should say allowing tim hortons to use
his title and his name to basically make
all the money that he makes with the
royalties or the sponsor or whatever
other you know extremes we've already
talked about it
you have a business owner right who
doesn't do anything just business is
just doing itself other people are
maintaining it uh i could go on there's
a lot of ways yeah but in inshallah
today the focus is going to be on active
income
and uh
i want to hear what you guys have to say
so far i just want to jump in and just
for anyone who didn't understand what
that what those meant you know active
and passive didn't understand the uh
explanations it was really good i don't
think there are people out there that
really don't understand it but just in
case um i have a really really like kind
of simple explanation you guys know
those yeah this guy
um you guys know those apps that people
love for some reason where they get to
like swipe and then they make like a
fake dollar on the app every time right
it's one of those like money making apps
where it's not real money or it's like
fake monopoly kind of thing right and
you can open your phone and see billions
of dollars that are fake right
it's the difference between active and
passive is like when you first start out
on these apps you have to swipe and to
make every single dollar you physically
swipe then you get a certain amount of
money maybe 20 30 50 000
and you can buy some kind of upgrade
that starts swiping the money for you
when your phone's off in your pocket and
that's the difference active is you have
to swipe to make the money like you have
to work to make the money right that's
active passive is just buy the upgrade
kind of like starting a business you put
your phone away have someone else run it
you go screw off whatever and then it's
making money in the background going to
your bank account
that's a good explanation very good
martial
the one thing that i want to add
about the active income is that for a
long time i was actually working to not
have to do anything for active income
and um uh alhamdulillah i got to that
point just for a brief period and i
realize how much it sucks
like as men we actually want something
we want to have purpose we want to have
a mission yeah so it's like
active income is very important but the
passive income now this is the i'd say
the most important part because yes you
want to have your mission but what good
is having the mission if you're
constantly struggling and like you're
mentally erect because you're always
trying to wonder where the hell am i
going to get the money to support my
family and all this stuff right but if
you have a passive source of income
that's providing you
the finances
where now you can fully focus on your
mission kind of like how we were talking
about before we did this podcast
it gives you that mental space and it
gives you the energy to go
all in
to your mission
to your purpose versus only being able
to give like 10
into your purpose right let's give a
beautiful example to let's say somebody
loves to do work for masjids they love
to open new masjids they love doing
fundraisers and stuff like this but
here's the thing bro they got kids they
got a family they got people to feed
they got people relying on them right
so what do they do
they can either spend most of their time
working at a job
active income right
and less time doing what they really
want to do or
they can realize that okay i have a goal
let's say 10 years 15 years eventually i
want to get there to a point where i
have passive income
so i have the money coming in because of
what i've done
and that is the the unsexy truth that
you have to start with active income to
eventually get to passive income when
insha'allah once you get there
eventually in the future if allah wills
then you can have the faculties
the time the freedom the security the
resources the means to then do whatever
endeavor you want to do
most of the time these endeavors are
things that will not make you as much
money
you know that's what i found out to be
the truth most of the time not every
time
um
but there's more barakah and those
things sometimes right oftentimes so
it helps to have that safety net and
money coming in so essentially that's
that's all it is with active income but
once you do get the passive income it's
not like you just have money coming in
you're gonna be chilling that's that's a
miserable life bro uh we had a brother
on the podcast a couple
weeks ago i would say hamza you know so
some of you might know him and he said
he made a video once saying that he
retired at the age of 22 when he was
making like 25 km a month
and he did it for about a couple days
and then he gave up
he said it was boring
there's no there's no meaning to it he
was recording videos for like four hours
a week at that point and when things
were popping off he said it was
miserable bro there's no purpose there's
no meaning anymore in life
but anyway let's bring it back so active
income
what is active income so you start out
working at a job right
my best advice to anyone would be
to not work at a job where there's no
room for growth
if you can do something like go to
school
while working a job that's fine because
you're you're getting some type of
credential some type of a skill some
type of a trade some type of a
certification whether it's a diploma or
a degree don't go after no gender
studies degree i'm telling you right now
it's a waste of time how dare you no
literally 100
don't go after women's studies degrees
don't go after humanities degrees social
sciences there's so many waste degrees
bro if you want to be an engineer lawyer
doctor
medical radiation scientist
ultrasound technologist
um you want to be a mechanic
you want to be an electrician something
that's going to make you money cool do
it if you have to work at a part-time
job or full-time job simultaneously go
for it
but otherwise work at a job where
there's room for growth
if you are someone that's easily
replaceable
then they're not going to promote you
there's no way they're going to promote
you you're not going to move up the
company the goal is to move up the
company go from you know worker employee
to like hire you know either a
general manager or or top tier manager
you're not going to be the owner
obviously because you're inside that
business but you're getting up the
ladder
you are now the employer you are the one
hiring other employees you are making
more money now for less
time
i'll give a beautiful easy example um
i'll pull out me because martial army is
very simple insisting the answers so
this easy example we give is let's say
you want to be a psychologist
okay or or a counselor therapist
something like that right
so a lot of people are looking for
therapy today um so may i make it easy
for us
but for counseling or therapy
if you go to school and you get your
counselors certificate or if you get
your license or you have a psychology or
whatever degree master's in psychology
and you want to work for
a clinic
right it's not your clinic
they're probably going to charge you you
know or they're probably going to pay
you 30 an hour
you see a client you know you or a
patient you help them out you get your
30 an hour
the business is charging the customer 60
per hour
so they're making 60 from the patient
and they're paying you only half
is the business doing all the work or
are you doing all the work
you're doing 100 of the work for 50 of
the money
whereas the business is doing zero
percent of the work and making fifty
percent of the money if not more i've
seen business make up to eighty ninety
percent of the money for doing none of
the work while the employee slaves away
they're dispensable they're disposable
they're replaceable and they're making
maybe five to ten percent but let's just
say for this you know ideological fairy
tale scenario
fifty percent
your job is to get so good
so many you know good reviews experience
all that that one day you can become the
person that's self-employed so from
employee
self-employed is the first step in
active income you're still not in
passive income though so i hate the
mercy of bubble dinner getting excited
but
you're just self-employed
once you're self-employed that's dollars
that you charge the patient you keep
that yeah so there's no
thirty percent there's no fifty percent
tax cut you don't pay you don't get a
split you are the business so you keep
hundred percent now you can do two
things you can either raise your prices
when you get good enough and these are
for service based industries obviously
by the way or you can work more hours
but there's gonna come a point when you
cannot raise your price more it would
either be unethical or unfeasible
and the price market doesn't work or
you cannot work hours because time is a
is a finite type of resource that we
have week to week so what do you do when
you can't work more than 100 hours a
week and you can't charge more than
let's say a thousand an hour for
whatever you do that's like the upper
limit now you hire someone else
but let's say unhealth psychotherapy
this company has built up so much of a
reputation and they trust you so much
that they know if angel brings another
therapist to the team they're gonna know
how to get the job done
so now angel becomes a person
that charges the patient 60 bucks
and gets this individual this employee
to work and takes 30.
so now you're making 90 per hour you're
making the 60 from your own hour
and you're making 30 from taking there
but you're not going to hire one person
you're going to hire a couple
sooner or later you're going to get to a
point where your business is doing so
good you don't even have to show up
you have a team of highly trusted
individuals and employees that work for
you and they're bringing you a lot of
money by the way this is still service
based business by the way this is not
another type of we'll talk about
eventually you get to a point where
you're so good
on health psychotherapy can become a
franchise
so now you open multiple franchises you
you hire managers
employers you hire a team they do your
thing you come in to get your paycheck
every week you take the split you're
making the most money doing the lease
work right
and you are now
this is the first step of passive income
which is a business owner now you have
the cash flow for all the hard work
you've done but you don't have to do any
of the work
[Music]
this might take anywhere from a few
months
if allah was it
two decades
yeah for service based
yeah but it's a game
you got to play it long enough your game
yeah
so
now that we have clarified i just got to
make sure i'm not playing footsies with
ronnie
but now that we clarified active income
passive income
now it's
let's talk about
debt
cause that's that's a big one here for
people would they were actually less
they're making money they're actually
making some money on active maybe they
might even have passive as well
but they deep in that debt
and they didn't choose or
they did actually they didn't they
didn't want it to happen but they are
you know and like of course
it's not halal we shouldn't be in debt
we shouldn't be doing anything that has
interest but it's like come on let's
let's be real today's day and age like
most most people they they definitely
are
this is haram yeah
haram you don't want to be indebted to
anything
so what what can we say here what can we
say for these people who are in debt you
know like what's the best way to really
tackle this to
um pay off the debt in as quick as way
as possible with
little to zero interest got you
around me well i mean are we talking
about
you know getting a loan that would put
you in debt without interest or pay your
dollar you're already in debt okay
well
from my perspective deep well
ten seconds bro real quick i'm just
gonna say this
prevention is the best cure yeah right
fire avoidance fire prevention then
firefighting you never want to get into
debt in the first place this doesn't
mean don't take student loans and and do
this i'm we're not giving photos here
but it's best not to get into debt in
the first place but if you're already in
debt
yeah 100
uh first i'm going to answer the
question actually first i want to
preface by saying one thing then i'll
answer questions shut up if there was a
way like let's say someone had a
business model that they're doing and it
works for them and there's a way they
could optimize it they just don't have
the funds currently if they could get
some interest-free loan like let's say
they live in some
utopia of an islamic society they can
get an interest-free loan um that would
be what they consider good debt right
because as far as you know it's gonna be
a good investment and your company is
gonna bring two three four five times as
much maybe in the next year or so you'll
pay it off in maybe a few months a year
and you'll be better off your business
that's not bad that is not always bad
also or so right here when it comes to
actually being in that and having to pay
it off and having this interest or
whatever you're already you know falling
into first you have to understand this
is a very bad position to be in it's
actually a very bad position to be in
there are people
like mosquitoes
like fleas like ticks like whatever
insects rodents that are feeding feeding
off of you and your basically disability
or your
um
what's the word i'm looking for an
ability inability thank you yes you're
and it is a disability as well you know
financial disability yeah but your
inability to pay it off they're feeding
off of that that usually exactly they're
feeding off of that
um again i'm looking for the word it's a
big word bro i can't think of it i don't
know i found a lot your um
your vulnerability
you're feeding off that vulnerable state
of being unable to pay and that's very
dangerous because that especially if
it's compounded interest it will
accumulate and accumulate
so much more you will end up paying more
in interest than the actual initial loan
itself of course it will take 5 10 and
he says of course because it is of
course that's how it's literally
everywhere you'll take 5000 out and then
be twenty thousand dollars in that
because you took so damn long to pay it
off and it's just compounding
accumulating so understanding position
but
you know
no stress no no worries no uh no
pressure inshallah and then after that
basically gotta pay it off my my guy
basically said well you're finished and
i said oh just take a shower guys
they need to know how serious it is this
is why allah has made haram very clearly
unequivocally haram in the quran
right
or you believe do not basically
get involved with usury
doubled or multiplied
means exactly but basically he's telling
you to be from the good people
essentially right
um so
when you're in this position you just
got to pay it off now the way to pay it
off is you know if you're working if
you're doing what you're doing now that
has not allowed you to be able to pay it
off you're doing you have to do more
basically not that you're doing
something wrong but you have to do more
which means you need another avenue to
make money now again i'm not going to
tell you what that is right maybe it's
freaking power washing driveways or
homes or whatever people do that kids do
that nowadays and they make money then
you hire a bunch of other power washers
to do power washing for you then you
hire a marketing team to market for you
and then you expand and grow and then
you make money and then you can pay off
your inshallah
if you don't have another source of
income that is bringing lots of money in
and you're doing things the halal way
here inshallah then you're not going to
be able to get out of it and
unfortunately there what's the statistic
how many well i forget what's the
percentage of people that are in debt
the vast majority of people
are 80 to 85 percent if you're 95 yeah
are in debt credit card debt
medical bill debt insurance debt student
loan debt some type of debt yeah
subhanallah people are taking reba based
loans to pay off a fifty thousand dollar
hundred thousand dollars five hundred
thousand dollars today
instead of having their tawakolan allah
this is the generation of people that
we're living in
and women that are actually demanding
this
yeah yeah and it's um and it's not just
a little bit of debt you know me you
know i i'm alive i'm young right so i
haven't really been exposed to all that
stuff
so the people like me no they don't
understand that this is like some people
are extremely in debt like they want to
you know off themselves because of it
like literally they cannot sleep at
night because of it right
it ruins them their family's life so on
and so forth and well let's discuss it
may allah
guide
and or punish the people who do this
because walla is discussing the banks
are absolutely horrendous for it oh they
don't care
damn sense about you bro yeah yeah
bro when you said that it just gave me a
moment to reflect on how grateful i am
and
brother and brother bro we're not in
crippling debt
you know how of course you guys know you
can only imagine but
how much of a blessing it is to not be
in this cycle bro
where people take 40 to 80 years just to
get out yeah
yeah alhamdulillah such a blessing i
would say
again i'm not a financial advisor with
what i'm about to say
um but i heard that there's this method
to uh
get over that now i don't know how loud
this is
okay so i'll explain it here that we you
know dissect a little bit but i want to
bring it to the table because like you
know dire times calls for dire
measures yes thank you
it's like a lot of fair oh yeah so
you have
these cards right credit cards not
supposedly i don't not supposed to open
a credit card got it understood
now you have these cards where they
actually offer you a interest-free
period
um on balance transfers or on purchases
i think within like the first month
if you do these transfers or purchases
in the first month they'll give you like
18 months where you have zero interest
whatsoever
now it sounds good because
you essentially have like
this time frame where you can pay it off
without any interest but here's where
they get you if you don't pay it off
mm-hmm
that's what makes most credit cards oh
my that you're yeah you're signing up to
the possibility that if i cannot pay it
in time i'm going to be agreeing to reba
wallahi they are bending you over
and i'm not even going to say the rest
don't you ain't got to press the button
but you ain't got a
all right so
basically you have this this period now
i've heard of people what they do is
like let's say they had
a card open right now and this card um
[Music]
they're being charged interest
monthly
they have let's say for example 5k
in debt
now they can keep the 5k in this card
and keep paying the interest every
single month or they can open this new
card here
and now they have a loan they have 18
months they have 18 months right 18
months well they can transfer this
balance over now now they have the 5k in
this new card
where it has zero interest
they can pay off as much as they can and
then once
that card is coming to an end they open
another card and then they transfer that
over there now look i'm not saying this
is a lot nor am i saying this is even
the best way because i think this would
actually
kind of mess up your credit score yeah
but i mean again like dire times cost
for
dive measures so like this
i don't know what do y'all think like
this is
do you think this is something a little
too extra
that people should be doing or do you
think this it's a it's a valuable
um well again
given the same disclaimer not speaking
about any or any rulings i think um i
think to us it seems extra but for a
person in this situation it won't seem
actual it'll seem like what just what
they need to do so i would honestly from
that perspective i kind of understand it
um
rest assured they're probably not going
to get a loan after that
after two three cards
are probably done you know the credit
score is back at like 150 or something
yeah
i don't think it lowers it too much
again we're not financial advice yeah no
i think
when it comes to credit cards it's crazy
but like the more credit cards you have
open the better your credit score is but
it doesn't also depend on if you can pay
your stuff off and on time
of course but it's weird but like the
more cards you have open the more the
higher you can but the credit score is
basically a ranking you have in the
matrix if you really think about it they
want you to open more credit cards they
want you to get more loans and pay it
off obviously
to seem like you're progressing in
something
now i'm not here anti or pro
credit scores obviously
but there's ways to get a decent credit
score permissibly yeah i think we should
put that first and foremost and rely on
allah for risk at the end of the day
that's where it's coming from anyway
yeah but as brazil said bro these credit
cards are dangerous but it's crazy like
you said it's like this credit score is
part of the matrix where it's like
what's the credit score really for it
it's
for
to take another loan yeah take another
loan
finance a car finance a car get deeper
into it exactly so it's like they want
to know like yo how good are you at this
how good are you at paying us back this
is haram
haram damn oh
it's like that's a gym for y'all right
there yeah yeah
no wallahi bro like this is these are
things that no one talks about or thinks
about but let's say this you're already
someone deep in credit card debt
you have
years of student loan that now you're
getting on dean you find out that it's a
major sin bro
there's gonna be a shield bro that's
gonna be made for you so you can face
off against allah's mention of messenger
so allah salaam on the day of judgment
for anyone that even deals with riba
this is not something that is a game
something that we should take lightly
i don't want to go against them
subhanallah i don't want to
so what do we do
sleep well
marshall oh no this one's a sleepover i
like that bro
um do you have a reminders too saying
drink your water
i do
i have those on my phone okay i need i
need reminders for that so i don't know
otherwise i'm not gonna drink any water
bro but
main thing here is
bro you you don't make me forget now bro
yeah i pulled another bro guys how about
we wrap it up and we make a very concise
thing for people or two
we could make a part two for sure but
definitely we just make a little concise
like summary of what we
yeah yeah
today today's more today's more of like
just
some ideas about financial literacy that
people might want to know a couple gems
here right
but again guys
these are always unscripted
yeah so you either love us or you hate
us you know we're not here making
scripted lectures these are not
university college you know tutorials or
anything like that yeah but it was a
wonderful episode nonetheless
we're not we're not we're not selling a
course here all right so what you pay is
what you get you're not paying a thing
so this is what you get
that was funny
the last thing last thing i'm gonna say
is uh i think it was your line uh no
risk no risk right
um no he is
yeah there's no idea that's what he just
said i i just wanted to say because it's
rolls off i've been learning i've been
learning
what do you think about anaheim right
now
it's it's actually a lot better than i
thought
[Music]
yeah he's working he's working no i
really brought my teacher in each part
it's so good bro he's about to recite
surah al-bakar right now for you
ali
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is enough guys if we're going to
keep spamming this uh soundboard right
now if we don't wrap it up inshallah
it's over midnight right now
we are absolutely cracked right now all
right there's so much energy but we're
also sleepy at the same time it's
probably why the energy has been all
over the place
but please smash this like button if you
made it this far
out on all streaming platforms apple
podcast spotify soundcloud google
podcast sound box you name it there's
too many to mention right now
alhamdulillah
but please share this with someone that
needs this message of saving money
it could be your mama it could be your
grandmama
it could be your daughter
it could be your pet dog
that you have outside as a guard dog
because you live far into the
countryside permissibly
do your thing do you do diligence
and with that being said on her close it
off bro and remember
smalling money don't make a man
but a man better damn sure be making
that money
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello
[Music]